the reason people aren't successful
because they're so scared to fail yeah
so the thing I need to just know
everything up front everything up front
before I take an action actually the
only way you can learn is by taking one
step at a time and figuring it out as
you go along that takes a lot of courage
because you're very vulnerable because
you could very easily fail and sometimes
I do fail but again I'm not I'm not
really interested in trying to look
smart
or look good to fail no I'm not scared
to fail I just want people to see how it
works in the real world and I know the
failing is actually part of success and
that's part of the message as well so
you're gonna fail but you're gonna fail
your way to success and a mistake is not
about being a mistake it's a lesson so
first started my properties you know I
was getting lots of tenants I'd lose the
ast contracts I'd forget who'd moved in
and what they paid I wouldn't be I
wouldn't have the correct insurance it's
like the detail stuff my philosophies
always to look at the big picture and to
focus on the big picture which generally
speaking serves me well I mean at the
moment I've got you know you know you're
you're part of it what a big training
company we've got marketing department
customer service department sales
department we've got advisors and
coaches finance department logistics
operations team that deal with all the
venues and stuff but there's not one
person here that works in the company
where I haven't done their job at one
like probably badly even though even the
videography that you do right now and
all that I've done that at one point so
I mean I think the story talking about
is my first crash course when people I
did literally everything everything I'm
not just talking about the background of
booking the venue and marketing into it
I'm talking about when people arrived
there would be me on reception hey you
know I would sign them in then I would
go and usher them to their seats and if
there wasn't enough chairs out of the
stuck chairs
then I'd go onstage hey welcome and then
I'd facilitate everything when people
wanted to buy books or whatever I'd then
go back and I'd be taking the payments
and finding out the forms everything
then the event would finish and then I
to clean up the room and you know just
absolutely and then before people even
left the room might be there with my
phone
taking testimonials and then putting
together like a trailer the movie
trailer with what happened following up
with everyone everybody afterwards like
it was just me and I think you've got to
be prepared to do that and if an
entrepreneur if you want to run a
business but you're too proud to stuck
chairs then you probably shouldn't be
running the business you've got a bit
better view to do it to do anything and
everything that doesn't mean you should
be the person that always does it
because if you're really the business
you've got the stuff to worry about you
obviously times now you go I'm not
talking about not is not valuing your
time but you've got to be humble enough
to do everything within the business
every time I take things to a new level
I then envision the next level and just
keep pushing and keep pushing keep
pushing it most people what happens is I
think where most people get a bit of
success there then relax off so they are
Manor I'm financially free now that
means I can quit my job and I don't have
to work and then they just they cool off
a little bit or their business gets to a
certain size where they think I'm
comfortable now or this is a good size
but for me I've never done that and I'm
still learning young I'm 28 but I've
been in business now just over a decade
and every time I take things to a new
level every time I'm like wow I don't
stop and pat myself on the back and say
isn't it great
oh this is good I'm comfortable I just
continue pushing it continue pushing it
and I think oh I don't know how long
I'll be like that for but that's what
and when you have a momentum on your
side and you continue to put the
activity in the energy and it just
snowballs
[Music]